welcome back to good day las vegas we
are joined once again by metro sheriff
joe lombardo for our
morning cup of joe's segment sheriff
good to see you once again
good morning john so with the pandemic
we've certainly noticed that maybe you
have too a lot more people going outside
for recreation way into the desert
what kind of increased activity are you
seeing at metro
in the more rural parts of clark county
and maybe extra enforcement out there
yeah you're correct in your assessment
so we have a lot more people for whelan
a lot more people visiting mount
charleston
we've been concerned with some illegal
campfires
but in particular to the rural areas and
increased activity
ends up increasing our response with
search and rescue
a lot of amateur folks get out there and
start climbing rocks and doing what they
do or hiking too far
and getting medical distress so we've
had a significant
increase in search and rescue operations
which i am responsible for
a lot of people don't know that but we
have helicopter rescues and on the
ground rescues and
we've had a significant number of folks
been
in precarious situations that require
our response
recently sheriff we've seen uh some
standoffs around the valley
it happens from time to time but they've
ended peacefully suspects have been
arrested
uh sometimes uh without as a long drawn
out or any sort of a violent conclusion
there's been an effort by metro to try
and achieve that for a long time
what are the changes in tactics uh by
metro
on those situations to try and avoid
death so we we try to
uh make it a point of a tactical
consideration where swat is the last
resort
um earlier and you know in years past
swat
was called out sooner than later and uh
times
when swat shows up it escalates the
suspect it escalates the police
officer's mindset
and we try to give our officers
sufficient training
to de-escalate situations on their own
and we rely on the police officers
themselves the first point of contact to
achieve
the ability to slow down the action and
achieve de-escalation
but presumably there's a fine line
between wanting to have a de-escalation
and not turn up the temperature
essentially at a situation but also
trying to make sure that what was
happening beforehand doesn't escalate on
its own
how does an officer how is an officer
aware
of that so that they meet they sort of
read the room as they get to the scene
right so you know we we have we record
previous events so
a lot of times in people that have
mental issues
we've been there more than once and it's
important for the officer
if it's a different officer on a
different day of response
that they have all that historical
knowledge in how to react to this person
or how to address this person sheriff
thank you very much for joining us
this morning and we appreciate the time
we get every week
if you have a question for sheriff
lombardo yourself you can submit it on
our website eight newsnow dot com
and find out if the question is answered
every wednesday